الامطار تتجه الى الرياض لتقديم رونالدو
سلسله مطاعم بيتزا تسخر من نجم ليفربول
وغيرها نقدمها لكم من العربيه رياضه اهلا
بكم
تتجه الامطار اليوم الى ملعب جامعه الملك
سعود في العاصمه الرياض وهو الملعب الخاص
بمباريات نادي النصر حيث سيقدم النجم
البرتغالي كريستيانو رونالدو
عن اخره وهو الذي يتسع ل 25,000 متفرج
وكان لاعبوا مانشستر يونايتد السابق قد
وصل يوم الاثنين الى العاصمه الرياض
علمتني طائرتنا الخاصه
الطبيه في وقت سابقا من ظهر اليوم
الثلاثاء
فين انجلترا اصبح مهاجم ليفربول
الاوروغواياني داونز ماده السخريه على
السوشيال ميديا بعد الفرس الكبير التي
اضاعها امام نادي براندفورد حساب دومينوز
بيتزا على تويتر ساخره منهز بطريقته
الخاصه وغرد قائلا بانه يعتذر للزبائن عن
اي طلبات ضائعه الليله لان انه الناس
يعدوا عاملا جديدا ويفتقد للخبره التغريده
حاصدت اكثر من 6 ملايين تفاعل
وبعد قطعهما للاجازه التي تعاقب كاس
العالم منح مدربه
الثنائي استغل هذه العطله وتوجهها الى
امريكا
وفي امريكا ايضا شهدت مباراه
في دوري اف ال سقوط اللعب بعد اصابته
بسكته قلبيه وسقطها من بعض تعرضه لعرقل من
لاعب الفريق المنافس تعرض على اثره لسكته
قلبيه اللاعب تم نقل الى المستشفى على
جناح السرعه حيث عاد قلبه الى الحياه
مجددا لكن اللاعب لا يزال غائبا عن الوقت
[موسيقى]